pool free
rebound by
lebron james
[Applause]
he'll bulldoze his way
right in for two making it go
just eye-opening the way these guys take
care of themselves now there's a
turnover
westbrook nice pass to lebron
russell westbrook made it go well that's
three straight plays all by lebron james
and from the rest of the players and
really has improved his game rondo davis
a climb in the ladder
and with a nice dropping of the anvil
puts it down he got high with a great
feed
how about this just throw it high and
let the athleticism of a.d the best
defensive minded players and
facilitators
in draymond green i mean he likes his
chances oh davis again rondo
with another great connection with a.d
inside while airborne
both ways and rondo again
it's all about connection and chemistry
beautiful lead path there by rondo
finding a.d
james and bialitza
[Music]
lebron was six
lebron with nine a nice triple right
there by the king
the lakers
davis had 12 but lebron a perfect four
of four
if you are an nba fan there is no better
destination than nba tv their
season preview shows they put together
good spin by lebron
puts it up corkscrews for two
tipping right there for two nice hustle
there by lee beautiful lead pass by
westbrook
to carmelo anthony
[Applause]
look at this move right here look at all
the blue jerseys
three blue jerseys around nathan
you can't leave scotland anderson on an
island here against lebron james
get us in help
at least dig
they've liked his preseason
lebron who hasn't played in three of the
four preseason games leading into
tonight over to scandal anderson with
the beautifully orchestrated fade away
17. higgins finds toscano anderson for
three
with the rebound taken by anthony
and westbrook
chiseling got it to go
russ with a nice move